what's up everybody welcome back to my
channel Richard on data if this is your
first time here my name is Richard and
this is the channel where we talk about
data data science statistics and
programming subscribe for all kinds of
content just like this and hit the
notification bell so YouTube notifies
you whenever I upload a video so I have
a confession to make to you guys I
really really love Julia I really do so
she came into my life around this time
last year and there's just this thing
about her she's really really reliable
and sometimes I'll just be sitting here
I'm working on a data science project
and I asked her to do something that she
does it and really really fast at that
it's just it's really amazing and I'm
talking of course about the Julia
programming language what did you think
I was talking about last week I did a
video on our vs. Python and I tried to
break down how these two languages
compare to each other as far as metrics
like how easy are they to learn the
relative capabilities and their
popularity in the year 2020 just how
things like that are concerned but
there's a lot of people talking about
and asking questions about Julia so I
thought it would be appropriate to see
how Julia compares to these other
languages which have been around for a
considerably longer amount of time I'll
be going over everything about Julia but
mainly focusing on comparing it to our
and Python as a frame of reference
because I'm sure a lot of you watching
this already have some degree of
familiarity with either R or Python
before I do that some background on me
as I talked about in some of my other
videos I have been an hour programmer
for over eight years I actually picked
Julia up for the first time around this
time last year and I did a couple data
science projects using it also some paid
trainings but I'm not an expert on it by
any stretch of the imagination so this
video will be partially based on my own
experiences but also partially based on
just what people out there tend to be
saying about it Julia was launched in
the year 2012 and it was created by some
absolutely brilliant mathematic
go minds I'll list out all of them in
the description of this video but the
main motivation behind creating Julia
was to combine the ease-of-use and the
overall utility beautiful syntax all
that good stuff you get from Python with
the performance and speed benefits that
you get from a language like C and like
R and Python it is an open source
language with a ton of libraries which
are created specifically for data
science as far as size is concerned just
to give a bit of comparison between the
three languages
Python has about two hundred and
fourteen thousand packages developed at
the time I'm making this video R has
about 15,000 and julia has about 3,000
obviously this is not a total apples to
apples comparison because the focus of
the three languages is totally different
python is a general-purpose programming
language ARS main focus is on data
analysis and statistics Julia's focus is
on scientific computing Julia also has a
pretty impressive number of downloads at
the time I'm recording this video again
January of 2020 julia has been
downloaded some 12 million times though
as far as things like the tie OB index
are concerned it does lag significantly
behind R and Python at this time so we
can start by thinking of Julia the same
way we do of R in Python it's a
full-stack programming language and the
packages out there for it are designed
to conquer your standard problems you
run into in the data science world so
things like you start with your data you
need to clean and tidy it up get it into
a different format then you need to
create some kind of reports or
visualization or model right now the
packages in Julia are equipped to do all
those things then from a computational
standpoint Julia is built to have
multiple dispatch asynchronous i/o and
it's compiled rather than interpreted so
the basic translation of all that is
it's very flexible the performance is
really good and the multiple dispatch
aspect of julia is huge because this
basically means it's going to be
flexible and you're not gonna have some
of the weird and erratic behaviors and
errors which you could possibly see in a
lang
like our our Python as far as a user
community is concerned it's been my
experience the julia community is super
friendly super helpful also the julia
developers themselves have a lot of
tutorials up on youtube here as well
they're really well done really
professional really helpful however the
community is significantly smaller than
the r or python communities that's just
a function of its 20/20 julia hasn't
been around for as long so if you're
googling or searching on Stack Overflow
for the answer to a question compared to
R or Python you are unfortunately a
little less likely to find the answer to
that question at least right now then if
you're wondering how easy it is to learn
Julia let me answer that question a
couple different ways if you already
know Python you will pick Julia up
immediately
the syntax of Julia is incredibly
similar to the Python syntax so much so
the half the time you might not even
realize you're not coding in Python now
if you don't know Python and even if
you're not familiar with any other
programming languages Julia is probably
one of the absolute easiest that you can
pick up in fact it's just as easy if not
even easier than Python is and that's
just because the syntax for is so clean
and so simple I don't necessarily
recommend learning Julia as your first
language and it's just a popularity
issue I would learn sequel before any of
them to get database fundamentals down
and then learn Python just because
Python could be the most popular
programming language in the world in a
couple years but if you do learn Julia
first I don't think you'll have a bad
time with it and now we have to talk
about what's probably Julia's biggest
selling point which is obviously speed
so Julia was built for speed and for
runtime and this is primarily because it
was built for parallel computing and
granted you can get this effect in
Python but it does require some upfront
work because Python simply wasn't
designed with parallel computing in mind
so Julia themselves report some pretty
incredible speed comparable to something
like C so if you take a look at this
micro benchmark comparison again this is
poor
by julia themselves but if you just look
at the distribution of times that it
takes to run various algorithms and code
patterns julia is going pretty
impressively fast in fact it goes
significantly better than most things on
this list go fortran java javascript
matlab mathematica python r octave
julia is pretty much blowing all of them
out of the water now you may be thinking
well that's great but Julia themselves
are reporting that what are other people
saying well most third parties myself
included seem to be corroborating that
statement julia is really fast and in
fact it's faster than Python now this is
an example from the hacker noon blog
basically they ran a sorting algorithm
over 10 million randomly generated
integers and they compared the runtime
that this takes between C Python and
Julia now the results are pretty
interesting this wasn't necessarily true
for a small number of integers in fact
in that case Python was doing better but
at a high number of integers Julia just
destroys Python it's significantly
faster however there is one current
caveat on Julia speed and this is what's
known as the time to first plot problem
so what this basically means is that the
first time you execute a command Julia
might take a surprisingly long time to
do it now this is because Julia is
what's called a just-in-time compiled
language so it requires your packages to
be compiled when you run some kind of
process that requires them so your
current workaround to this is just to
keep your session open for as long as
you can the first time you run something
it may take a long time but every time
after that it'll be fast and you'll be
in the clear but obviously there are
some concerns about this namely from a
scalability perspective as well as just
the perspective of sheer optics however
this is something the Julia developers
are aware of and are working on so we'll
just have to wait and see what happens
as far as data manipulation is concerned
julia has what's called the data frames
package and
has all of your standard functionalities
like reading data filtering rows
selecting columns joining creating
mutations doing group summaries you have
all of these functionalities it's very
similar to something like pandas in
Python and in fact I was pretty
impressed with it
I thought the data frames package was
really fast I had no complaints
whatsoever with it
Julia also has a lot of different
visualization libraries probably the
most popular option right now is just
called plots and this package is
equipped to be compatible with a variety
of different backends so for instance if
you want to make Python style graphs a
common back-end typically used is just
the PI plot backend there's also a
variety of extensions using the plot
lead JavaScript API if you want to do
fancier things like interactive plots
now if you're like me and you're a fan
of the grammar of graphics framework and
the ggplot2 package and are there are
some similar options for you in Giulia
there's the gadfly package and there's
the Vega light package and these will
operate through that same type of
framework here's the thing though these
packages do not have anywhere near the
level of maturity and sophistication
that something like ggplot2 does and to
be fair to Julia this is actually the
same criticism that I have of pythons
visualization libraries but from my own
experiences with Julia's plotting
libraries there's almost always been one
little thing that I wanted to do just to
take my graph from good to perfect
and I haven't necessarily been able to
figure out how to do it using julia yet
now granted if you're not like me you
don't consider yourself very particular
or very picky about graphs you probably
don't have to worry about it any kind of
basic graph you are going to be able to
do using julia now as far as
interactivity is concerned i've already
mentioned that you can make interactive
plots they work quite nicely as far as
taking something like that to the next
level and doing something like an
interactive web app we're looking at
something closer to shiny and i
mentioned in an earlier video shiny is
one of my all-time favorite packages and
while the developers do have it on their
roadmap there's not
and answer in Julia for interactive web
apps that has anywhere near the level of
reliability that something like our
shiny has and again to be fair to Julia
Python doesn't really have this either
I've mentioned in my last video
pythons - does not have anywhere near
the sophistication and the ability to
handle complex requirements that are
shiny does as far as an integrated
development environment is concerned
julia has what's called Juno that's
probably the most popular option and
it's accessible through the atom app
there's also the eye Julia package which
just allows Julia to interface with
Jupiter notebooks the same way a lot of
people write Python code I talked about
this in my R versus Python video but I
do like our studio more than any of the
above I think Juno has a fairly similar
design I did like it but it is clunkier
and a little slower than something like
our studio is and again this is the same
criticism that I have with Python and
again I like our markdown more than I
like Jupiter notebooks but for your
reporting requirements you don't really
have to worry it's just a matter of
personal preference Jupiter notebooks
will get the job done now lastly if we
think about modeling there's a lot of
different options out there for that
starting with machine learning julia has
its own implementation of the
scikit-learn api which works absolutely
great and in fact if you want another
option out there is to use the PI call
function this is just a function which
calls python code using julia and you
can call the python scikit-learn module
both of these options from my limited
experience with them worked absolutely
great as a full disclosure I haven't
done any statistical modeling or
statistical tests using julia yet but
there's a lot of different options out
there there's the stats models package
there's one called multivariate stats
there's one called distributions and
there's tons of other statistical
libraries out there which makes sense
because Julia's focus is on scientific
computing now again I haven't
actually use these myself I've read
commentary out there on them and I
haven't heard any complaints or really
any major shortcomings with them now as
far as deep learning is concerned julia
has essentially an official deep
learning framework and it's called flux
now I have actually gotten the
opportunity to play with this not
through an actual data science project
but through Julia's official paid
training and I was pretty impressed with
how quick and easy the syntax is
naturally it's deep learning so there's
gonna be a deep learning curve to it but
it's not horrible and you can probably
pick it up fairly quickly feedback on
flux appears to be pretty promising so
far there are some odd speed complaints
that I've heard about it but nothing
that particularly raises any serious red
flags overall if you were to ask me in
the year 2020 is Julia a major
competitor to R and Python I would have
to say the answer is surprisingly
nuanced and I'm gonna start actually by
summarizing the biggest setbacks of
Julia and to me the biggest one right
now is the current lack of package
maturity because it just happens to be
the case some packages right now have
some bugs they need to work through and
if we take long term tried trusted
solutions let's say for R for
visualization we have ggplot2 Julia just
really can't live up to all of that
right now
however I don't actually think that it's
totally fair to pit julia against r and
python which are languages which have
been around for a much much longer time
and in fact I'd be incredibly surprised
if Julia isn't a huge player in the data
science scene in three to five short
years this really comes down to speed
which Julia was designed for from the
ground up frankly the amount of data
which is generated every single day is
absolutely mind-blowing so the era of
big data and just the requirements
surrounding it that's not going anywhere
so it's easy to scoff at Julia doing
something faster than Python in the
order of a few microseconds
but when you're dealing with billions
and billions of Records those
microseconds do add up honestly today if
you're doing smaller and simpler
analyses I can't imagine you having a
problem with Julia and in fact I think
you'll be completely thrilled by it I
don't honestly think we're ready today
for large scale models which are put
into production environments but
especially when we consider Julia's
parallelism advantages there is huge
potential there I don't recommend
learning Julia as your first data
science language again I would know
sequel before anything else then I would
learn one of our or Python master it go
back and know enough of the other one of
those two languages to be dangerous then
you should probably pick up Julia at
some point it's easy to learn and it's
something that at the bare minimum it
should be on your radar as we move into
this decade so thanks for watching this
video leave a comment below and let me
know if you've used Julia and if you
have what your experience with it was
I'll see you guys in the not-so-distant
future until then Richard on data